all right turning back to the fight
against the coronavirus earlier we told
you how federal officials
are raising questions about the latest
trial for the astrazeneca vaccine
it shows that trials are complicated a
new study based in the u.k is trying to
figure out
what happens when different types of
vaccines are deliberately
mixed up when they are given to
volunteers only on cbs this morning
charlie dagda is in oxford england with
a first look charlie good morning
good morning to you anthony this kind of
covit 19 trial
has never been done before and
scientists say the results might not
only revolutionize the future of vaccine
distribution
it might offer the best defense yet
against emerging variants
rika trika has no idea what's about to
be injected into her body
no not at all no leave it in the capable
hands of the doctors
a blind leap of faith not just testing
one vaccine but deliberately mixing them
up to see what happens
more than 800 volunteers aged 50
and above taking part in the oxford
university-led
trial some given a pfizer prime
shot followed by an astrazeneca booster
or
astrazeneca followed by pfizer others
the same vaccine twice
the standard way for comparison shots
separated by 4 and 12 week gaps
to see which works best professor paul
heath
is principal investigator at one of the
eight trial sites across the uk
with that knowledge then we can have
complete confidence
that a number of different vaccines can
be rolled out and implemented in a
in a population very quickly very
efficiently without any concern
about inadvertent mixing of the
combination
you're talking about potentially
increasing flexibility
capacity not just the pfizer or
astrazeneca vaccine but potentially any
combination of
any covid vaccine easing inevitable
supply issues
around the globe not only that professor
heath says alternating vaccines could
even produce
better overall protection against
emerging variants
potentially with a prime boost of
different vaccines
the broader response the broader immune
response that ensues
will be sufficient to deal with for
example the south african variant
it's like a preemptive strike the body
will have a
perfect better defense yes
as unpredictable as the virus has been
two
challenges ahead are absolute
certainties
global shortages will only worsen and
the virus will continue to mutate
the results of these trials may offer
the best hope yet
in solving now for those who have
already had a vaccine it's unclear just
how long that protection lasts
if we have to get a booster the results
of this trial may give us an
idea of whether we'd be better off
switching it up next time
anthony charlie daggett in oxford
england thank you charlie
all credit to those volunteers i'm not
sure i'd want to participate in that
study but i'm very curious about the
results